en estas imágenes los manifestantes son
disparados con munición real una nueva
jornada de movilización en sudán se
cerró con varios muertos y heridos a
pesar de la represión y los gases
lacrimógenos la resistencia contra el
golpe de estado del 25 de octubre no se
debilita semana tras semana
choudary lo que tenía esos jóvenes
sueñan con un gobierno civil de paz
libertad justicia y desarrollo nosotros
somos personas mayores sin futuro pero
las demandas de esos jóvenes deben ser
atendidas a dogma para luego la fecha
del 17 de noviembre es simbólica ese día
la presidencia del consejo de soberanía
debería haber pasado a manos de un
gobierno civil sin embargo hace un mes
el golpe de estado del general abdel
fattah albur han hecho por tierra esa
esperanza y puso fin al proceso de
transición donde el poder se repartía
entre civiles y militares una situación
que la comunidad internacional de flora
como mencionó el secretario de estado de
eeuu
anthony blinken
durante su visita a kenia
sudán estaba en el camino hacia la
democracia y la estabilidad volver a esa
vía es la mejor manera de que sudán
logre la paz y la prosperidad se
convierta en un líder en el continente y
recupere el firme apoyo de la comunidad
internacional se espera que las
manifestaciones continúen en los
próximos días